okay let's go from something serious to
something not so serious I do want to
get to hatred mail quick reminder about
what hatred mail is it's like taking an
apple pie filling it with pages from the
Old Testament topping it with hollow
points and serving it with a side of
homophobia Patriot Man
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom all right no introduction
necessary for this week's hatred mail
let's take a listen to it together
comment great Shh your views are warped
and you are a sellout and leftist scum
your liberal screwed viewpoints suck and
I hope that the world's morals remain
intact before you're sickening
Democratic ways being implemented on us
tries to get it to be normalized and
accepted I never get the sellout thing
like who have we sold out to and what
are the big benefits we've received from
selling out don't you think if we had
sold out I wouldn't be talking about
people donating a dollar on patreon
every other day and who would we even be
selling out - I'm not are so many
conflicting groups III think it's code
for either the Democratic Party or Jews
of some kind like George Soros or Israel
or something like that they're not
saying that but usually those are the
key players in that one well I like
skewed spelled with a Q skeleton x you
don't even see the letter Q and whenever
you can put it in there I think you
should extraneous use of cues I'm
absolutely in favor of and it seems
Patriots are as well coupon code Patriot
forty use the coupon code hey tree at
forty two turn hey tree at mail into
something that benefits the show back
after this